so uh today we saw critical race theory
was trending
and one of the things that really
worries me the most about
whatever this is right i think i
actually think critical race theory is
the wrong way to describe it
we are giving the battlefield to the
left by using
their terminology this battle this
culture war has been going on for a very
very long time
and you can say the first modern battle
in the culture war
was gamergate then we see you know
movies video games
comic gate etc where you started to see
this critical theory
whatever you want to call it some people
call it cultural marxism i think that's
a bigger umbrella term a better umbrella
term for a lot of what it is
wokeness is an easy way to explain it
colloquially but when we talk about
critical race theory
it's easily masked by the woke they just
say oh it's just an academic theory and
you're overthinking things
and we shouldn't ban academics for
children but what's happening is
critical race theory is a core component
it's just the racial component of
critical theory which is
quite literally an advance on um or i
should say developed off of
karl marx's thinking and the frankfurt
school i don't want to get too jargony
but it essentially is a totally
different moral framework
from christianity you know the united
states uh and as mostly as my opinions
but you guys can feel you know feel free
to chime in
it's built on a christian framework
christian moral framework
you look at what ben franklin what ben
franklin said about
it's better that 100 guilty persons
escaped than one innocent suffer
which was just taking from blackstone's
formulation it is better that ten guilty
persons escaped than one innocent suffer
which was just taking from the stories
of sodom
or sodom and gomorrah which i believe he
quite literally said
so we we end up with a society where you
have a lot of secular
liberals atheists etc who are living by
this moral framework
they don't understand it though you know
over time we've moved away
from the more i guess societally
enforced
you know um i don't want to call it
theocracy
but societally enforced religious views
or faith and
understanding why we have these these
moral frameworks
by losing that something else comes in
these woke people believe there is no
truth but power and therefore they are
entitled to lie cheat and steal to get
whatever they want
until they gain power so i'm curious
your thoughts you wrote
and you can talk about your book and
explain to us what your thoughts are i
think you called it political
catholicism but uh yeah
sure no i mean i think that's right that
the fact that uh they're moving in
to me um shows is proof
that there was never going to be any
kind of a neutral public square
that our societies will one way or
another always enshrine some orthodoxy
some authoritative view of what it means
to live a good life
some account of the highest goods of
human life what is what what's the
purpose of living
one way or another a society will
enshrine that and for a long time the
society had a
as you said a kind of christian i would
say kind of a a protestant establishment
a protestant consensus and then in the
you know
much of the 20th century catholics and
jews were added to the picture
we started using terms like
judeo-christian and that was the
consensus and
um but a certain element of liberal
ideology which i think this this our
society is ultimately a liberal
civilization
has this tendency to be very suspicious
of of orthodoxies
of uh uh uh you know
attempts to enshrine um ultimate meaning
in the public square and so it chipped
away at those
culturally politically over a long time
and we see that
in the vacuum that was created the wokes
moved in
right so and now they're moving very
quickly every element of
national life you know corporate uh
businesses
you know universities almost certainly
obviously but now k through 12 education
there's not a not a one dimension of
american life where you can escape
it so to me that just shows neutrality
is over
and it was always an illusion there was
always going to be some
account of what it means to be happy
what it means to be good what it means
to be
exactly fully free the woke the
whatever their you know they call
themselves or whatever it is
they need people to believe there is no
conflict they need people to believe
we're just teaching about
slavery we're just teaching history no i
mean they're quite literally fabricating
with the 1619 project
it is a a i i would i would argue it's a
different moral framework but i think
it's just a lack thereof
it's no it is it's it's it's a it is
as these things often are it's a kind of
bastardized christianity and i think
you said that tim so for example it has
an element of original sin
but the original sin in in biblical
religion
is something we all inherit and so and
you have to
you know seek redemption through faith
and so forth
but the opportunity for redemption is
open to everyone and everyone is equally
fallen
except the blessed virgin mary
but but so now we have the concept of
original sin but it's
sprinkled across different groups
depending on your skin color
you are you know forever tainted by
racial sin and have to spend your life
trying to expiate this with racial sin
and and if you're a minority or you know
fit whatever intersectional boxes the
more the better like trans disabled
black blah blah blah
exactly then you're sort of part of a a
holy class you're sort of
uh you know you're unless you're an
apostate unless you are
say john mcquarter or something like
that
well i think this is interesting because
so you were sort of suggesting that this
this wokeness leftism critical race
theory
any of these similar types of thought
are
a moral system in it of themselves and
you were sort of alluding to them being
a lack of moral system i think what it
is is a moral system without any virtue
or any emphasis put on virtue
and so it can be very confusing to suss
out exactly exactly what it is
and i think you're also right that it
was impossible for there to be any kind
of neutrality
ultimately what the government has to
have is some kind of definition of what
a human being is because you can't
govern something without reference to
what that thing is
yeah and so if humans are created in the
image and likeness of god and the
government believes that it's going to
govern a certain way
if human beings are just blobs of
organic material that happen to have
amassed consciousness through some
information processing at the level of
the brain and there's nothing inherently
value about us metaphysically
the government's going to govern in a
very different way this is actually
really interesting
because i think we had a conversation
about aliens on
on this show maybe a few months ago
would would the constitution protect the
rights of an alien
if like if like an alien spaceship
landed on earth and these you know
little grey men came out
would they have free speech right so
they have constitutional rights and you
know typically when we talk about this
people like well of course i mean
they're you presumably people and it's
like okay well if it's a different
entirely different species of being then
why do not dolphins or elephants have
constitutional rights
in which case there there is a presumed
definition of who the law applies to
and it's a human being yeah and i would
also say too when people get into
discussion on aliens obviously
it gets extremely theoretical but the
question is are we talking about
a creature which has free will because
people will say things like intelligent
life well how are we defining
intelligence i think ultimately it's
does this have free will does it have a
soul so to speak or a rational soul well
you know what else is our people
as corporations according to our
government legally and you want to talk
about modern day religion
we're living in it the corporate
corporatocracy maybe that's what this
should be a corporatocracy not a
theocracy
yeah it's interesting you know and you
were sort of talking about this but how
all
a lot of this intersectional stuff is
really just a corporate religion too it
helps them because
you can look the other way on how
they're abusing their workers as long as
they're giving money to the right causes
and promoting wokeness you know they all
they all change their twitter
bio picture to a rainbow flag this month
so i guess they're nice and progressive
we don't have to worry about anything
they're doing but yeah i think it's
interesting that that um
wokeness you can kind of trace its birth
i mean
gamergate is interesting but that it
came after occupy wall street
i actually it was it was it was at
occupy it was well no but the thing was
like occupy
was making i i think now at the time as
a conservative i was like oh these crazy
leftists but yeah
in fact after the i don't know but after
after
what what uh kind of big finance did
with a great recession
in fact those demands weren't now in
retrospect i think weren't so crazy
because
the the idea that you would privatize
all the gains but then socialize the
risk onto people
that's that's outrageous and that was
crazy but that
movement didn't work and what instead it
turned to is instead of a kind of
class-based
movement having to do with legitimate
economic injustices and overweening
corporate power in this country
it shifted to wokism which is
really really easy for for corporations
to accommodate
i actually think that was intentional
during occupy wall street during the
first week or so
actually i know a lot of people are like
where's luke at we we demand
luke no luke i puke so uh our friend
he's a he's like an ancap libertarian on
luke whatever you describe yourself as
uh we met during occupy wall street and
he's he's libertarian right
and i was very libertarian left but we
both met during occupy wall street in
new york
there were conservatives down there
sitting in with on you know sitting down
holding up the american flag during
occupy wall street it was very much just
a general populist movement
complaining about the one percent the
elites and then something really
interesting happened
a lot of conservatives came out against
it and there were conservatives there so
that was you know for me i was kind of
surprised
i actually interviewed some an older
couple and then the woke came in
all of a sudden the conversations around
wealth inequality turned into racial
inequality
all of a sudden when you started making
demands about the big banks stealing
from the working class they said you're
white shut up
and then immediately conservatives and
libertarians started leaving not wanting
enough pardon us probably not wanting to
sleep in a park probably
that's fascinating i didn't know that
and then we started seeing the rise of
the i am the 47
movement which to me was also very
strange why were a bunch of people
deciding to be opposed
to a popular economic populist movement
i mean i think bannon just the other day
said tax the rich you know
yeah today yeah so so to me i was kind
of like
i was like oh i totally understood what
they were saying but the people who
initially came down and were protesting
the establishment the elites
ultimately what i ended up experiencing
i went to the deplorable
when when donald trump was elected and
i'm there i'm like wow it's a bunch of
conservatives you know i don't know
anybody i know who some of these people
are
and then all of a sudden some people
come to me like hey tim we're big fans
and i was like oh really i didn't
realize trump supporters you know like
watched
my live streams and my youtube channel
and they were like no no we were down at
occupy wall street and i was like in
your trump supporters oh yeah yeah yeah
like
screw the establishments through hillary
clinton trump's the one who's gonna
knock that all down
so what happens is wokeness shattered
the the economic populace moving after
2008 and now we've been entrenched in
that battle where i think we are very
much distracted by it the problem is
these these they they saw an opportunity
to move in they woke they saw a
grievance
and if they saw an opportunity to
manipulate and i think most these
corporations saw an opportunity to as
well
yeah if you shift this to this kind of
stuff
um you know as my friend christopher
caldwell says uh um
where he says uh you know in in
various realms of life whether it's
public corporations or or or government
they will just say like well you know
we've done nothing for the working class
we've done nothing for the working poor
but you know what the new ceo is is uh
is a trans woman and you know so it it's
just
you shift power within elites according
to like hierarchies of
intersectionality without actually
shifting economic justice
right right one one iota thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.comcast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you